the 5th century in Greece started off
with the persian invasion and ended with
the Peloponnesian War and now we're
entering into the 4th century in Greece
and as we entered to the 4th century
Thebes is the dominant city-state but as
we get into the mid 4th century and
especially the end of it we will see
that all of Greece gets dominated and
then unified by the Makedonians or
the Macedonians and in particular the
first unifier here was Philip of Macedon
and this is a bust of him and he's known
as he comes to power in 359 BCE he comes
to power his father was king of Macedon
but then his older brothers died he
becomes it's actually his nephew who is
heir to the throne he becomes regent for
his for his infant nephew which means he
has the power temporarily but then he
actually takes full control and becomes
king of Macedon or makaton as it's often
pronounced in 359 BCE and what he then
goes off about doing is taking over most
of the Greek city-states and eventually
he's able to unify most of the Greek
city-states and you can see on this map
here which i got from wikipedia this is
a little bit of information about the
map you can see how he expanded his
empire over time that remember 359 BCE
he becomes king of Macedon in 352 he's
moving into he's moving into Cecily then
in the end the three forties he's going
into the race so he's going into
Thrace and Molossia and Molossia is
interesting, the king of Molossia he
actually ends up mattering his he ends up
marrying the king of Molossia's daughter
Olympias who ends up being alexander the
great mother and she's a pretty
interesting characters we will see a
little bit she was part of this cult
that worships snakes is believed that
she slept with snakes
but he goes off and continues to conquer
eventually he's able to subjugate most
of the city-state's of Greece except for
Sparta and that takes us that takes us
2 337 right over here where he is able
to establish the League of Corinth it
was only called the League of Corinth after
the fact but he gets the leaders of the
significant city-state together in corn
that's why it's called the League of
corn and they swear their oath
essentially to Philip king of Macedon
who they call the hegemon and what's
really important about that is he is
able to unify the Greek city-state
outside of Sparta and in doing so he
sets things up for his son the famous
alexander the great the Great to
continue to unify Greece alexander the
great's actually able to subjugates part
up but then more famously he goes off to
conquer the entire persian empire and
then beyond in his short life and will
have at least another video on that but
just to get a feel for what happened at
the League of Corinth in 337 BCE i will
share this this oath that the various
city states had to commit to and it says
I swear by Zeus gay Helios Poseidon and
all the gods and goddesses I will abide
by the common piece and i will neither
break the agreement with Philip nor take
up arms on land or sea harming any of
those abiding by the oats nor shall I
take any city or fortress nor harbour by
craft or contrivance with intent of war
against the participants of the war nor
shall I depose the kingship of Philip or
his descendants nor the Constitution's
existing in each state when they swore
the oath of the peace nor shall i do
anything contrary to these agreements
nor shall allow anyone else as far as
possible but if anyone does commit any
breach of the Treaty I shall go and
support as called by those who need and
I shall fight the transgressors of the
common piece as decided by as
decided by the council and called on by
the hegemon who is that when this when
the oath is made who is Philip of
Macedonia now unfortunately for Philip
this happens in 337 where for the most
part he's the first to unify the Greek
city-states outside of Sparta but he's
only able to live about a year after
that
a year later we're now in 336 BCE and
he's in the old capitol of the mat
kalonian kingdom which is very close to
Pella celebrating the wedding of his
daughter to his to his brother-in-law so
his daughter who is who is Alexander's
sister she's being married to Olympias'
brother so he's marrying his
daughter to her uncle and it is during
that wedding that Philip of Macedon is
killed by pase Gnaeus who is his
bodyguard and there's a lot of really
interesting stories he's killed at the
wedding in 336 BCE and there's a lot of
really interesting stories about what
the motivation for Policy Gnaeus was
there are many accounts that say that
Posse Gnaeus was Phillips lover he was
on some level jealous and he was on some
level because another relative of Philip
fronted Palestinians and Phillip didn't
go to defend him
there's some narratives that this was
arranged somehow by Olympias, Phillips's
wife and the mother of Alexander to put
Alexander on the throne there are some
motivation there because also a shortly
before the assassination he took a
second wife which was his more favored
wife as opposed to Olympias so there's a
lot of really interesting account and i
encourage you to read up on it but the
interesting thing is is after he gets
assassinated
well then there's a bit of a a scrabble
scramble for power but it leaves
Alexander the Great or eventually is the
Alexander the third officially but
eventually Alexander the Great
becomes becomes the hegemon and he's
eventually in his short life he's only
20 years old
when he becomes king he is able to as
we'll see in the next few videos take
over all of the Persian Empire and
beyond and subjugates party so he
further unifies the Greeks and takes on
the mighty Persian Empire